Are you alone in the universe or
are you connected to anything?
First of all, you're part of a group
of mammals that's still very young,
but we can make youtube videos already
and build large Hadron collider as we've
also split the atom and invented Pokemon.
We stem from an ancient life form that
began living about three and a half
billion years ago. We feel like
we're in control of this planet,
but we aren't rarely one little
asteroid or one creative virus is ready.
All it would take to kill us off for
good humanity credits itself with being
able to destroy the planet,
but even with all our nuclear toys,
we would probably be just cause
a huge mass extinction of best.
Maybe we could kill 90% of everything
living on this Panisse big deal.
A few million years later,
life would be back everywhere.
Most of microscopic life and life below
the surface wouldn't even be disturbed
that much.
Probably on a geological time scale.
Our impact on earth is kind of laughable.
We're actually not that powerful.
We live on this tiny wet rock that speeds
through space following a massive ball
of burning plasma.
One day,
this ball of plasma will stop burning
and most likely kill us in the process.
If we survive the death of the
son and colonize the galaxy,
theoretically we could survive until
the last star in the universe goes out.
After that life becomes pretty impossible.
Okay,
so everything has an end. Where does
this leave you as an individual?
At one point in your life,
for about half an hour,
you were only one single cell
inside your mother's womb.
The creature just not 0.1
millimeters in diameter. Today,
you consist of about 50 trillion cells,
50 trillion,
incredibly complex little biological
machines that are much bigger and more
complex than the average bacteria.
They operate by the laws of physics
and chemistry and use micro machines to
build proteins, make ng usable,
devour foods, transport resources,
transmit information or reproduce.
They communicate, duplicate,
commit suicide,
fight off intruders,
and fulfill super specialized duties for
the greater good of keeping you alive.
So you can have babies,
but where is the you part in this?
If you're made of
trillions of little things,
but basic information for you is stored
in the DNA and molecule that encodes the
genetic instructions used
in the development and
functioning of all known living
things. If you were to unravel
it, it will be two meters long.
If you combined all the digital
DNA strings in order ourselves,
you'd get a string so long that it would
stretch to Pluto and back to Earth.
That's pretty long and your DNA is a
direct connection to your very first
ancestor. Take a second to think about
this. In every cell of your body,
there's a little string of stuff that's
been there in various forms for 3.4
billion years. It evolved, it mutated,
it duplicated trillions of times,
but it directly connects you to the
first living being on this planet.
We could say you touch to every living
being that came before you with your Dna,
but you are more than your DNA.
Your body is made of
seven octillion Adams.
That's 7 billion billion,
billion.
Roughly 93% of the mass of the human
body is made up of just three elements.
Oxygen,
carbon and hydrogen.
Oxygen and hydrogen are
predominantly found in water,
which makes up about 60%
of the body by weight.
Carbon is maybe the most
important element for life.
It can easily bond with other atoms
which allows for the building of long,
complex chains of molecules which
make up the solid part of you.
The remaining 7% is a tour of
the periodic table of elements,
nitrogen, calcium, phosphorous,
potassium, sulfur, sodium chloride,
magnesium ion fluoride, zinc, copper,
iodine, selenium, chromium, manganese,
molybdenum, cobalt, lithium,
strontium element, Niamh,
silicon led vanadium asked Nick and Roman.
By the way,
there's also means you're
about not 0.5% metal.
No Matter Watch your favorite music has.
Anyway.
These elements perform various functions
like enabling oxygen transport,
building of bones and cell structures,
carrying signals,
driving chemical reactions,
and a lot more.
Your body is in a constant
state of transition.
Every 16 days,
75% of you has been replaced because a
healthy human exchanges about 100% of
that water in that time period.
Each year.
About 98% of your atoms are replaced by
new ones and every five years close to
all of the atoms that make up your
body weren't there five years ago,
so you could call yourself a
temporary collection of atoms,
but where did these atoms come from?
In the beginning of the universe,
they were mostly hydrogen
and helium atoms.
Enormous gas clouds formed over millennia
and grew denser and denser until they
collapsed under their own gravity giving
birth to the first das in the cause of
these stars, hydrogen was converted
into helium under extreme conditions.
After millions of years,
the hydrogen became exhausted and the
stars began dying under super extreme
conditions.
All elements we know today were created
a fraction of a second before they died
and exploded in supernovas.
They shop most of their contents into
space while the cause collapsed and became
black holes.
All these elements traveled through
space for who knows how long until they
arrived at a different cloud that was
slowly forming a new star, our sun.
These elements that once with the insides
of a star formed planets and found
their way onto earth where
they enabled life to begin.
So we are directly connected to the
first stars ever born in the universe.
We are heart of the universe.
The idea with being deeply connected,
minuscule part of an enormous structure,
it's really mind blowing.
We don't know what all this means
or if it means anything at all.
We know that we're made of little bars,
the connectors to everything in the
universe to the beginning of everything.
And this is kind of a nice thought.
You are not alone. You never were.
You never will be.